America never wanted to lead the world
this way this unfathomable milestone is
one of its most tragic and indelible a
hundred thousand lives lost to
coronavirus nearly triple that of any
other country they are people from every
state and every walk of life Leilani
Jordan was 27 years old when her life
was stolen by Kovac 19 she loved
butterflies ever since an infant and so
I called her butterfly butterflies to
her was so free as coronavirus was
tightening its grip despite her own
disabilities Leilani told her mom she
would not give up the supermarket job
she loved mommy no one's showing up for
work I have to help the senior citizens
the elderlies they're in their walkers
and you know can barely walk leaning
over shopping carts and although she had
her disability she would go out of her
way to help them to get and find what
they needed because she knew sign
language she could even talked to and
help those that could not talk so she
loved helping and being needed by others
she always liked that as a little girl
always been like that
Leilani kept working until the day she
could no longer breathe she collapsed
before she made it inside the hospital
unlike the thousands robbed of proper
goodbyes it's an obeah was with her
daughter for her final moments I would
do anything in this world if I could
have my baby back
my butterfly I was there was she worth
the CCU
she took her last breath in my arms my
hands my last touch touching her body as
hos warm was her last breath Zenobia is
now living on her memories and with the
small comfort they'll Arnie's best
friend and support dog angel when you
lose a child as a mother some some
people don't have children but they have
animals that's the same kind of love so
angels lost her mommy
Nalani it's like angel knew what time
she was coming home now she sleeps by
the door The Nanny has two small sisters
and they make a video every day for her
singing to her how much we love you
America's deaths have been
disproportionately high in black
communities revealing long-standing
health and socio-economic disparities
Zenobia is now focusing her grief on the
urgent need for protections for
essential workers she wants them to be
better rewarded than lolani this is her
final paycheck 20 dollars in 63 cents
and you received that after she died yes
for all that she has done she should
have been getting paid way more money
six years and this is all you get as the
daughter of a military family lolani now
shares her final resting place with
fallen heroes in Arlington National
Cemetery
this new invisible enemy has now claimed
more American lives than the Vietnam
Gulf Iraq and Afghanistan wars combined
for a nation living in isolation it's
perhaps harder to share a collective
sense of grief even harder to tune out
the ongoing political noise of this
crisis but make no mistake America is
engulfed in tragedy with no cure or
vaccine this is not the end Amanda
Walker Sky News Washington